bonjour c'est un bon réseau aux sources
pour moi de présenter si cet après midi
quelques centaines de pieds de l'eau ou
mon aventure humanitaire personnel de
commencer et déjà un peu plus de 20 ans
en 1991 lors de ce qui est maintenant
considéré comme l'avant dernière grosse
débat depuis cette année à ce moment
alors lorsque les rivières chaudière
envahi le centre-ville de sainte-marie
la plupart des mariverains comme deux
scénarii poussé par ailleurs en beauce
la plupart des gens avaient trouvé où se
loger ou passer les quelques nuits où il
pouvait pas rester chez eux
j'ai des paras chez des amis des voisins
qui n'a pas grandi mais il y avait
quelques gens un peu moins fortunés qui
avait passé ce réseau social de qui
étaient venus se réfugier à la
polyvalente où la croix rouge étaient
venus monter un centre d'hébergement
et puis c'est là où moi j'étais allé
pour voir si je pourrais donner un coup
de main puis qu'est ce que je pourrais
faire pour pour faire ma part qui j'ai
juste que ce que la croix rouge faisait
ici puis à l'étranger et puis ça a été
le coup de foudre d'une histoire qui
dure depuis maintenant vingt ans plus
tôt
c'est une histoire qui m'a amené à
travailler non seulement au canada mais
aussi à travers le monde dans une
trentaine de pays
jusqu'à maintenant et puis j'ai vu bon
j'ai où j'ai travaillé j'ai répondu des
différentes catastrophes des tempêtes de
verglas jusqu'aux feux de forêt des
inondations des tsunamis de les
sécheresses malheureusement des guerres
aussi et puis sam approfondie ça m'a
permis d'approfondir cette démarche et
de s'aimer réflexion en fait sur mes
motivations sur ce qu'on fait ce qu'on
arrive à faire les limites aussi de
l'aide humanitaire et jeu
vous présenter quelques unes devraient
partager quelques-unes de ses réflexions
là avec vous je pense que quand on parle
d'ailleurs d'humanitaire d'assistance
humanitaire surtout dans le cadre de la
réponse d'urgence qui vient
immédiatement à l'esprit ben là c'est le
tremblement terre en haïti en 2010 où
c'était moi personnellement mon premier
déploiement comme chef d'opération où je
suis arrivé puis j'avais comme mandat de
monter une opération de réponse
d'urgence donc le 12 janvier 2010
c'est une journée comme les autres je
rentrais chez moi à pied
en fait j'étais à la recherche d'un
appartement puisse visiter un
appartement car
le téléphone s'est mis à vibrer c'est
mieux vivre et pas mal de regarder ou
gros tremblement terre
et puis tout d'un coup après les cours
hier c'était les sms qui ont commencé à
rentrer le les smr ça veut dire le
niveau d'urgence qui commencent à
s'élever à prayssas a été le téléphone
et puis là j'ai dit la dame qui me
faisait visiter l'appartement j'ai
débuté je pense qu'on va arrêter leur
parce que je pense que demain matin je
vais partir en haïti
donc je suis rentré au bureau et puis je
me suis mis sur skype puis là j'ai vu
que tout le monde était ravi le stade
soit en gros maintenant
et puis j'ai vu mes collègues qui qui
était à port-au-prince qui étaient
connectés j'ai dit comment ça va il dit
ça va mal on a besoin d'elle
j'ai dit la cavalerie arrive on voron il
dit envoyer tout ce que vous avez là ça
me fait peur parce que c'est un gars que
je savais qu'avec l'expérience et où
quelques heures plus tard je reçois un
message de mes patrons à ottawa pierre
genève qui ne disent tu pars demain
matin je prends l'avion pour saint
domingue en république dominicaine puis
nous avons monté notre opération
j'en ai dit j'ai pas beaucoup dormi
c'est nul on parle le lendemain je
retrouve une équipe qui était en train
de s'assembler c'est drôle ça fait 4 à 2
les masseurs pierre main
j'ai parlé des dizaines de fois par
super image est patent j'ai passé 5 ok
j'ai retrouvé mon équipe à sallaumines
curieusement qui apparemment une demande
qui avait des états unis on monte dans
un convoi rond ne pas et par un
supermarché on a pris tout ce qu'on
pouvait mettre dos de bof on descend
port-au-prince et on se rapporte
on traverse la ville et puis là c'était
évidemment au delà de tout ce que
j'avais pu imaginer il ya personne dans
mon équipe qui avait jamais vus sur moi
j'avais répondu au tour ou de tsunami en
indonésie en 2006
même ça ça des passes et c'était la
densité de population les difficultés
qu'on avait pour se frayer un chemin
on ne finit par arriver lowe's qui
allait devenir un centre des opérations
et puis lors de sa commande gros de
l'opération fait que je me rappelle je
me rapporte à genève
on est arrivé on est pro père et les
girls ibos moses d'une avance budgétaire
de 100 millions de dollars
moi je même pas capable j'ai encore du
mal à imaginer ce que ça peut
représenter concrètement 100 millions de
dollars et puis ça s'est tout de suite
j'ai saisi non seulement je voyais les
besoins qui avait su le terrain mais de
j'ai senti que les moyens dont on est là
qu'on allait avoir à notre disposition
l'argent pour une situation assez unique
c'est l'argent ne devenait pas un
élément qui permettait de faire ou de
peau faire quelque chose l'argent le
devenir juste une unité de mesure de ce
qu'on allait faire
parce que quand on dit que 100 millions
de paires vois ce que tu as eu lorsque
besoin est toutes demandes tu viens
alors au cours des trois semaines
suivantes
tout ce qu'on avait ou à peu près on
l'envoyait en éthique c était une
mobilisation sans précédent
la communauté internationale des
hôpitaux des avions des hélicoptères des
bateaux du matériel de construction
la nourriture des génératrices ça a été
un effort dans un seul pays on n'avait
jamais vu sur console j'ai été rejoint
ma première mission en haïti pour la
réponse à cette urgence là ça a duré
trois semaines 21 jours j'ai été rejoint
par 300 personnes de 25 pays c'est assez
phénoménal d'être de faire partie d'une
équipe où des israéliens des turcs déjà
la norvège du colombien des deux partout
dans le monde qui viennent rejoindre
tous pour travailler dans la même
direction qui veulent tous accomplir le
même objectif
on a collectivement on s'est installés
loup on pouvait parce que tout était par
terre on ne trouvait des systèmes
entrepôt désaffecté dont des murs qui
est en arrière en fait qui est un mot
s'est affaissé ces données justes sur
cité soleil puis en ce moment est à la
meilleure place qu'on avait trouvé
jusqu'à ce choeur on avait une équipe
qui travaillait sur essayer de monter un
camp fonctionnels les deux premières
semaines on était là on était au plus
gros de notre premier cas on était 225
personnes
eon se partageaient de douche et
sainte-catherine fait que l'esprit
d'équipé
il ya des lots et le cdh ou semaine là
pourtant j'ai jamais entendu personne se
plaint des conditions des conditions de
vie des conditions de travail state of
on était malade et j'en faisais des
affections respiratoires on y tombe mal
en lisant prédisons mais pourtant
c'était tellement pire ce qui avait
d'ailleurs qu'il n'ya jamais eu personne
pour ce pagne donc au fil des jours au
fil des semaines on ne mobilise les
sources d'un hôpital de référence
quand je vous dis que l'argent n'était
pas un problème en fait c'est devenu un
problème parce que il y avait tellement
de volonté de réparer tellement de
ressources qu'il fallait essayé de la
canaliser fait les prioriser quand on a
un aéroport dans le pays qui est à
moitié fonctionnaires comme deux routes
qui relient avec l'autre aéroport qui
est en république dominicaine faut
choisir ce qui arrive parce que c'était
dans la première dans les premières
heures dans les premiers jours on fait
ce qu'on appelle du life saving donc si
c'est pas bien coordonnées si c'est pas
bien géré
un blocage et puis là on n'est pas plus
mal donc c'est une situation un peu
surréel ou une surabondance d'offres
qu'il faut faire absorber il faut que
faire faut faire distribuer sur le
terrain une mobilisation à la grandeur
de la planète
quand je parlais avec kevin
il y arrive c'est bizarre comme comme
fini irizar c'est je me suis retrouvé au
centre d'une mobilisation que je savais
qu'ils rejoignent qui rejoignait les cas
pour les quatre coins de la planète de
la thaïlande l'australie de la chine
l'amérique du sud sont les gens
converger vers haïti avec se crée une
impression
tous les médias du monde sont surtout y
regarder il y avait des caméras partout
ce film et puis tout le monde est à
l'affût des histoires antarès
d'enseigner une transmission d'horreur
une transmission de solidarité d
histoire de courage des histoires
répondre à tout ça sera en vente en
continu sur les écrans donc tu te
retrouves dans une ville en fête qui va
bien au-delà de ce que toi tu
représentes comme force ou comme niveau
d'énergie
c'est quelque chose c'est une expérience
d'une et ans tu mènes que j'ai jamais
vécue que je serai pas forcé de jamais
revivre non plus que nous et parce que
après ça moi quand je suis revenu à la
maison ça m'a pris sous mon amendement
remet puis avant de me rasseoir maman ma
réalité laisse quand on a vécu sort
quand on a vécu le rocheleau d'actions
et d'interventions faire les comptes de
dépenses les feuilles de temps
ça va aller dans des meetings où on va
parler de planification stratégique qui
s'appelle sens pas mal mais
éventuellement on se réajuste ses
réalités et on réintègre notre quotidien
qui ont fini par absorber ça ça a été
pour moi si un extrême et puis si ce que
je pense il représente le plus
facilement l'imaginaire collectif de ce
qu'on pense que l'humanité
l'humanitaire pourtant c'est pas juste
les situations comédie cette année il
demeure de janvier à mars j'ai été
déployés en république centrafricaine où
depuis plusieurs mois il ya de la
violence des conflits entre les
communautés
déjà qu'ils sont pris dans une spirale
de vengeance de rétribution que des
dizaines de milliers de personnes de
déplacées à l'intérieur du pays des
dizaines de milliers d'hommes qui ont dû
se réfugier dans 12 pays et il y aura
trop de ceux parmi ces genres et des
dizaines de personnes des dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui sont dans un
cadre à l'ère open ma mission c'était
encore de monter l'opération de la
croix-rouge effet de se demander bombe
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
j'étais leur cette semaine et malgré
tous mes efforts par là c'est cette
semaine là j'étais capable de mobiliser
une seule personne
cette personne là est un appui un
spécialiste en soins psychosociaux
puisque lui venu faire parce que pour
moi le besoin était tellement criant
c'est à venir appuyer les secouristes
locaux qui eux depuis des mois à tous
les jours montez dans leur pick up qui
allaient chercher des blessés ou lé
chercher les cadavres des gens qui
avaient été massacrés pendant la nuit
les besoins des gens sont dans le c de
l'aéroport sont pas différents de ce qui
est en haïti leurs aspirations sont les
mêmes mais la réponse
et paulo c'est c'est assez particulier à
gérer puis je voudrais le contraste ans
et répond cela était d'autant plus
criant pour moi encore plus fort que
pour des raisons de sécurité on était
dans un hôtel luxueux hôtel qui était
protégé par l'armée parce qu'on n'avait
pas de place où aller alors le soir
quand on se retrouverait après le
couvre-feu à césar pour essayer de
planifier la journée pour que ce qu'on
pensait il y avait leur caisse qui
jouait pendant ce temps là dans le
lointain
des fois pas si loin que ça on entendait
les explosions qui envoyait les lumières
des balles traçantes
pendant que la violence continue et
prend dans les rues ça c'est un autre
côté de l'humanitaire dont on parle
moins qu'on voit moins mais quand on
décide de s'engager dans cette
expérience là où dans cette carrière là
ça fait partie aussi de cirque on
s'expose fait que ce que ce que j'essaie
de transmettre aujourd'hui puis de
vouloir le 06 pendant ce temps alors la
planète regarder les jeux olympiques à
sotchi 50 milliards de dollars sur
l'organisation des jeux olympiques
sa préférée
ce que ce que je vais vous dire c'est
que voilà c'est moi j'ai vécu cette
extrême là d'un extrême à l'autre
et puis ça s'emporte un autre image un
peu ce qu'on considère en fait qu'une
carrière qui est assez romantique ou un
engagement qui est assez romantique
c'est un sas et c'est beaucoup diffusé
par les médias on voit les vedettes qui
viennent les célébrités ça aspire
inspire et ça pousse les gens à vouloir
aider je dis pas qu'il faut pas des
bonnes intentions ça pas je pense que ça
commence avec des bonnes intentions
sauf qu'il ya un risque au modèle de
l'aide humanitaire
c'est celui de la charité en fait c'est
celui de marie laure parle un peu c'est
celui de la victimisation
quand on s'approche avec une 14 déploie
quand on va sur le terrain avec nous
avions pu nous y capte puis nos
ressources plus tôt c'est facile de
mettre la personne dans une position
d'infériorité
les personnes qui ont aidé et lundi
matin disait cet après-midi de vie le
brésil disait on devient aveugle à la
personne derrière son handicap elle le
risque de l'assistance ou du modèle
caritatif que dans l'humanitaire c'est
de ne voir dans cette personne là que
tout perdu qu'une victime est une
personne qui veut être une victime une
personne qui veut se considérer comme
une victime et on n'aide pas les gens
quand on les victimes il on tombe dans
l'assistance ya liste il faut s'éloigner
de sa pour leur donner des outils dont
ils ont besoin pour surmonter l'épreuve
qu'ils ont eue et les accompagner pour
préserver leur dignité
donc allez voir la personne derrière
donc faux comme jouet j'insiste sur le
fait c'est important d'avoir de bonnes
intentions mais faut être lucide pour le
reste des techniques de l'expérience qui
s'apprend ce pour moi je pense que c'est
un métier des leçons qui sont apprises
autotour qui ont été apprises au cours
des années
il ya moins technique pas de se
perfectionner mais comment on voit notre
propos de la danse et l'eau ça en valait
de faire ce que lui veut la tête
le kit d'eau c'est vrai évidemment que
c'est important mais ce qu'ils cherchent
c'est de la sécurité économique
la sienne sa famille celle de ses
enfants comme vous comme moi bien plus
que la tente bien plus que le kit de
cuisine qu'on lui donnait ça fait 15 ans
que je fais du terrain à l'international
se fait 20 ans que je suis le meilleur
et puis encore cette année en
centrafrique
gg j'ai saisi cette dimension-là de la
dignité de la portance de dignité d'une
façon parce que quand on est pogné dans
un hôtel le soir après le couvre-feu
l'heure on attend de réfléchir beaucoup
et puis un soir il y avait pour la
première fois cette année là ça a été la
pluie les saisons les plus recommencer
et puis d'habitude bon j'ai répondu sur
des sur deux périodes de sécheresse la
pluie c'est les bienvenus tout mais le
mot j'ai réalisé que la pluie c'est à
les transformer le champ de leucan de
personnes déplacées à l'aéroport en
revanche en bout et puis pour la
première fois parce que chez moi
maintenant j'ai ce qui m'attend qui me
tardait quand j'étais à la maison
spidla je me suis mis dans la peau de ce
père de famille là qui étaient là qui
peut même pas sûr et son enfant de
passer la nuit au sec
et puis ça m'a fait mal ça m'a fait mal
une façon j'avais jamais jamais je
n'avais jamais ressenti auparavant
en même temps le fait que j'avais mon
enfant la maison me fait aussi
reconsidérer le niveau de risque auquel
je suis prêt à exploser dans dans le
cadre de mes activités et comment
maintenant pour moi je vais penser
autrement mon propre travail parce que
je pense que l'or cette affaire ou de
georges mêla que d'aller courir le trou
je pense que maman va être content de
l'apprendre et c'est donc c'est en fait
celle où je me trouve 1,9 pour dire ben
est encore une fois marie-laure tu
parlais de relations authentiques une
démarche authentique c'est aussi de de
continuer à se questionner je pensais
qu'après toutes ces années là passée à
courir la planète
j'ai encore plus de questions que j'en
avais encore moins de certitudes que je
l'aimais mais je voudrais quelque chose
par exemple je suis venu à park
ici il ya deux semaines pour première
cabane à sucre
et puis en passant par le centre ville
je voyais les gens qui nettoyaient leurs
caves qui cèdent en voisin il s'est
arraché les laines minérales et mais des
containers de bouffe des containers de
déchets excuse et qui me rendra fils et
de bouffe je vois des containers de
déchets puis je voyais justement à
l'entrée puis vous avez trouvé ça
bizarre mais j'ai trouvé ça beau voir ça
ça fait du bien d'être à la maison
bonjour voici